[Music]
[Applause]
he is reggie miller hall of famer member
of the nba 75th anniversary team of
course analyst for turner sports reg
will be on the call for the bucks and
sons this thursday night on tnt did the
lakers clippers last week and of course
he will be part of all-star weekend
festivities from the 18th and to the
20th the great reggie miller back here
in the man cave
reggie looks like he could still play
[Applause]
i'm bad
you know it's true i don't know
okay
little millie vanilli huh we back i know
we lead back minus
yeah
mclovin
it's okay it was a good run for him it
was a good run you know he overachieved
all right he went longer than he really
should have been with us right yeah well
you know we we love him it's like when
you lost ron artest you know it's just
like he's a valuable guy he over
achieved who moved on he overachieved
with us with the pacers came out to la
and won a championship but
we're not really worried about that in
indiana are we no okay uh favorite
football team growing up oh the raider
that's what i thought lester hayes that
was my guy number 37. oh but when they
moved here
did you get to go see them because being
in oakland you probably didn't no no i
never went to oakland
i think i went to one raiders game as a
kid yeah growing up
um so
raiders won a colts 1b colts were my
adopted team obviously being in indiana
for 18 years so those are my
two football teams
i'm an afc guy
so
you know people keep saying well who are
you going to pull for in the super bowl
obviously you're going to go for the
rams yeah like we didn't really like the
rams growing up
um i do believe the rams will win who do
i want to win i'm always a small market
guy
i'll always pull for small markets i
think that's good for any product in the
nba nfl
mlb
so i'm all in i'm all in with the
bengals how important was nwa
to the raiders
like overall
a popularity
huge i mean
we all have the hats the raiders hat
it's almost like uh how jay-z wearing
the yankees hat
so identifiable jay-z and the yankees
growing up it was nwa ice cube dre
easy e
wearing all black and silver that's
that's what we did as kids plus you
wanted to be the bad guy or the villain
anyway so that fit right in with the
raiders lester hayes was my favorite
player um did you ever meet him no never
did
i mean
he used to put all that stick him the
stick i'm on i mean i never played
football if i was to play football
that's who i wanted to be because him
and ronnie a lot were like they were
everything to me but your parents
probably your mom wasn't going to let
you play football no look at me
look at me cheryl could have played
before
cheryl would have been a better football
player than i would have been
how much do you weigh now and how much
did you weigh when you retired i retired
i weighed 193
because of my cycling now
i'm down to
yeah because i'm on the bike yeah you're
thin you're thin i'm not thin i would
say i'm
you're lean i'm lean lean er
yes no you're good i'm okay it looks
like you could still shoot you could
still shoot
that'll never leave me you know that
yeah now again if you ask me to get out
there and move my feet yeah that's a
different story i all you got to do is
be stationary you can play they just put
you in the corner they were handing out
these 10 days look i
i mean demarcus cousins has less
mobility than you do i can run to a
corner yes and shoot a three yeah fall
back into a 2-3-3-2 zone i'm good
fall back into his own i told everyone
fall back into a zone
sign me up for a 10 day i'm there what
is the headline of the nba season so far
i think it's the young gun teams you
look at cleveland
uh charlotte
uh minnesota memphis memphis though
memphis made the playoffs last year even
though they're a young team i think
they're ahead of the curve than some of
the other ones i i mentioned
jaw has been fantastic he's in the mvp
obviously discussion and running
but it's been the young teams and
probably the disappointment of some of
the established teams or teams that we
thought were going to be at the top the
lakers obviously brooklyn has lost eight
straight obviously they're you know kd
with the injury hardin's been out the
last few games and the whole kyrie
situation
so we're disappointed in the blue bloods
but we got to be excited about some of
these young teams
do you still look at phoenix as the team
to beat in west milwaukee in the east i
say phoenix and golden state out west
and memphis scares me because they're
young enough
and they're dumb enough and they've got
a point guard
who is not scared of anything and like i
said they've got playoff experience for
what they did last year
i think out west are out east no one is
talking about miami
and they are the one team that scares me
because they
constantly play defense
they're well coached champion coach
and they've had
so many injuries and they still continue
to win injuries to jimmy butler bam
lowry and they've all found
an opportunity to still win ball games
to me in the east it's milwaukee and
miami as the two best teams
but
right now if you look at the standings
brooklyn is sitting seven they're in the
play-in situation right but if you're
one and two do you want to see brooklyn
in that play-in situation win that and
then they're gonna have to face number
one or number two i don't wanna
i don't want that to happen so i think
brooklyn will move up once kd comes back
but my favorites is miami and milwaukee
in the east yeah i'm trying to figure
out what the nets do if there's been all
of this smoke where are they going to
trade james harden they deny this ben
simmons i get at what point are you
you're trying to prove a point but do
you do a disservice to this nets team
uh
by just keeping them you know whatever
this lineup is i watched james harden
the other night right
he looked terrible all right and i know
he's got decent numbers but
um
i don't it feels like he doesn't know
where he is on that team is kyrie
playing tonight
katie's out or katie's not you know
what's my role here
it almost feels like he's not having fun
the way we usually expect that with
james harden and
everything you said is spot on
here's my only thing
how a healthy brooklyn with katie kyrie
and james
it's going to be so difficult to beat
them four out of seven if they're all on
the same page now again it will depend
if mandates change if kyrie can play
some of these home games or he's only
gonna play on the road games
to beat them four out of seven when
they're healthy and whole i mean that's
asking a lot
they've only played 17 games together
since they've been together so that's
the challenge
i look
i think james has gone after this season
i don't think they're going to trade him
but i do think he's gone after the
season so the question for brooklyn do
we trade him now and get something for
him or do we lose him for nothing that's
i think what
the the nets brass is probably kind of
wrapping their head around now
explain to me how chris paul
with feels like limited athleticism
still can dominate again and get you 25
wait he's the last true point guard it
feels like in the nba and you watch him
he's not fast he's not big
not quick
uh can't jump
but i've never seen a guy or remember a
guy who finds spots he he finds his spot
and he he takes advantage of that and
he's very very smart he is the greatest
leader
probably along with lebron james in our
game he is so smart and he understands
everything you just highlighted of his
deficiencies he understands
how to win ball games and where he can
be successful on the court and now you
pair him with an up-and-coming young guy
who
can give you buckets in devon booker you
surround him
phoenix
and their team
they're brilliantly coached by monty
williams and they've got a bunch of
specialists
they understand
their roles no one's gonna out step
outside the boundaries for them
mikhail bridges i know i got to play
defense and knock down corner threes
ayton mcgee bismack biambo who they
found somewhere in a bus stop
i understand i got to rebound set
screens and roll hard and run the floor
so cameron johnson i come off the bench
i shoot threes no one's trying to do
more than what they're asked of and they
understand that and that's why they've
been so successful and then you couple
together they're well coached
and you've got the best leader general
in the game in chris paul that's why
they have the best record he's reggie
miller the hall of famer a member of the
nba 75th anniversary team he'll be on
the call for the bucks and sons thursday
night how much of a surprise was that or
was it a surprise to be on the 75th huge
i i didn't expect it
um
because you look at the top 50 that was
25 years ago all those guys deserve to
be on it and obviously they're they're
on this one as well so it was really the
next 25. so when they were announcing it
and they got to the last day of the last
25
and my name had not been mentioned how
did you find out
on air
um oh that's right i had just done that
piece with steph curry and that's what i
thought we were going to talk about with
the guys in the studio so they had me
come over early for a west coast game
which i thought was a little odd because
they were on early in the east coast i'm
like why am i coming over at two o'clock
to talk about this step piece when we
just talk about it right before the game
i was like all right i'll do it anyways
because the piece was cool
and i know they were announcing the next
25
and i was doing the math like they
hadn't mentioned shaq or dwayne wade or
a whole host of other guys so i got up
to about 19 or 20 i'm like well i'm not
going to be one of those five
of the guys that have not been announced
yet
and then as you saw the rest when ernie
said how does it feel to be teammates
with steph and i'm like what are you
talking about like
i interviewed him you know he's like no
you're on the 75 team i'm like
oh
and then i said something else
yeah i cause i didn't expect to be on
there i hope to be on there
i would put my resume up against anyone
of the top 75
but
i mean i didn't win a championship
my numbers are great but
you just never know so i'm very honored
to be on there
um it's the greatest team it's almost
better than being in the hall of fame to
be on the 75th
one of the 75th top players ever in this
game
it's kind of cool
let's go through who you're better than
let's run down no no
no no no no no no no because you get
more into who didn't make it you know i
dwight howard unbelievable resume klay
thompson unbelievable resume uh tracy
mcgrady vince carter
alex english um
these are all guys that some i've played
against um
all deserving you don't walk by dwight
howard and just kind of walk a little
bit
look what four or five or three or four
times defensive player of the year
um a champion
absolutely not because again it's all
in the eyes of the beholder it really is
that was a couple of days ago paulie
played the uh the kobe commercial
when he's having a drink and jalen rose
walks by one of maybe one of the best
commercials of all time
and poor jalen jalen sees him jaylen
goes
and kobe
got a martini like how many olives
81
and jalen
but it's the pause when they're looking
at one another right and then he's like
oh i'm just kidding a joke for my friend
right
he gets it and that was kobe that was
kobe like people really didn't
understand or he was misunderstood at
times because he didn't really interact
a lot with
the opposition
and but the difference between kobe and
mike with that personality trait
was what
i think or is it the same
both mike and kobe didn't interact
with
the opposing teams like i knew michael a
little bit
i knew kobe a little bit better because
we had the same agent
and i think
kobe was a little bit more
especially towards the younger
generation his younger generation
of helping guys out mike never wanted to
help anyone out he just wanted to
destroy he didn't care about your
feelings colby cared
a little bit
but michael didn't care
how you felt who you're married to he
didn't care about anything but
destroying you
but why do you think kobe had that
ability
willingness to help out the next
generation i don't know i think maybe
paying it forward
um look we'd all know that kobe idolized
mike
and
you know people say well who's the
greatest two guard of all time
to me michael is 1a but kobe's 1b now
that's not far off i mean it's 181b he's
not far off and maybe he just took bits
and pieces of mike's personality and
kind of changed them into
what he was like a little bit how is
lebron not dropping off
that's amazing right yes
look i i'm going to say this
this is his 19th year
at age 37 38 and three
seasons of playoff basketball it's
it's remarkable because
i could barely walk after games after my
18th year
i know he spells he spends well over a
million dollars on body maintenance and
it's well worth it um
but to play at this high level
against this competition and to be this
successful this lady in his career it's
kind of like tom brady
it's almost like we lost a family member
when tom brady decided to retire because
we all remember that comeback versus the
rams down 27-3 there's no way at 44 this
dude should be retiring we don't want we
want to continue the memory same with
lebron we want to continue to see this
and i tell people you better appreciate
it
while you're seeing it unfold with the
chris pauls the lebrons the carmelo
anthony's because we're not going to see
it very often or again
it's kind of remarkable to see does
lebron end his career as a laker i think
a lot upon depends on brawny
right it depends on
if and when he will be when
he's drafted and where he goes
it would kind of be cool to see them
play together i think lebron would
sacrifice playing here in la if
brawny got
you know drafted somewhere out east but
what if the kings draft braun
wouldn't that be fitting a king joining
the kings okay
[Applause]
patrick now you're back you are
back i could see him
ending wherever ronnie is drafted yeah
now are we sure that ronnie is going to
be drafted
i think name alone someone would take a
photo on him right yeah i mean i've
watched him he's not the best player on
his own team
but he does have those moments it's just
you're watching going
that's lebron's son i'm gonna i would
draft pedigree
and uh a young man who's seen
so much throughout his lifetime through
his dad's lens
i would take that experience and a shot
of getting lebron later on as well i i
would do that yeah polly you know how it
always goes bad for the knicks what at
the next draft ronnie james lebron
get over here
i'll watch on uh nba package
oh i can see the the knicks need help
they never get it right
why
i felt they had turned the corner last
year
randall was most improved they had made
the playoffs it was a good feel-good
story the knicks are back they open up
this season with an overtime huge win
versus boston everyone's going crazy
and then the bottom falls out it felt
like they were celebrating getting to
just a better than average level yeah
you know they beat the hawks one game
and the fan base it they you know you
would have thought they won the nba
championship and i thought these are the
knicks you don't act this way like you
want championships there not only do you
want championships but you want deep
playoff runs and they won the one game
against atlanta and then trae young
went crazy on them right yeah so
they're still
fighting for that plan seed in the east
but it's been a disappointing season
this year because of what they did last
season but do you think that owner is
going to keep people away with free
agency that durant was not going to go
there kyrie was not going to go there it
feels like with that ownership you're
not going to get players who are going
to entertain new york is a serious
destination i i can't speak to the
ownership i mean
it is new york
and there's only one way to go
if you're a new york knick and that's up
i don't know why you wouldn't take a
gamble and potentially go there but
because of social media you don't have
to go to the big markets anymore yeah
you can go to smaller markets and
still you know have commercials and make
money and so forth i i
said this to the danettes when i heard
that zion had off-season surgery and i
said this is a big deal yeah it is and
and then then it was like oh you know
he's not going to start the season and i
said guys this is a
serious issue that size that injury i
haven't heard a good update on zion
williamson and i haven't heard any
update on zion williams last i heard
that he was rehabbing on his own
somewhere in portland
that's it that's that's our update
look an all-star player we on we know
the talent is there
but to me it's always been about the
weight issue and i just think he's he's
carrying too much we we've been on this
show how many times have i said he's
carrying too much weight he needs to get
don't you buy him a bike get him a bike
he can come out to southern california
i'll get him a bike he can come ride the
hills with me he couldn't keep up with
you sure he could no he could not i
would crush i know i know crush
by the way the greek freak's now making
threes reg that's scary i know
if he ever
is able to do that consistently then
it's then it's not gonna be the key word
is consistently and will you trust that
in the playoffs yes uh you'll be on the
call you get to uh watch the bucks and
the suns that'll be thursday night
finals rematch and then all-star weekend
coverage as well
i'm excited about that uh you want to go
outside maybe shoot some hoops
we got a hoop here yeah it's out there
come on man let's go all right we'll
take a break let's go uh we'll be back
talk to you uh during the commercial
break here on peacock we'll be shooting
some hoops i don't think our form is
worth judging but but it might be worth
not either no no no no it's been a while
oh please stop it back after this
thanks aren't we supposed to open this
get this up higher or is that up oh
there we go
[Laughter]
that would have been tough to explain
you go home and
the wife's mad at me
ah mama bear is mad at me
like what do you what did they do to you
now you felt like shaq didn't you that's
how shaq felt
and and then i think that was new jersey
when he brought it down right
in the meadowlands
do you care about shooting anymore like
when you go to
when i do i started shooting when you're
around a gym do you want to like when
you're time i see an empty gym like the
garden when you go
okay sons and bucks thursday night yes
will you shoot i will not shoot you
don't care i don't care
only time i care now shooting is with my
son because he's getting into basketball
yeah he plays
but he plays the wrong way
what
what does that mean
because he comes out instead of properly
warming up and he's like step back
i'm like dude still curry didn't come
outside shooting 30 footers
come in here get you know get a proper
warm-up see that's the problem dad used
to shoot deep now he wants to get out
practice
there you go here you go reg
oh here we go fritzy let me see what you
got
no no
good night see that was nice outside
shooting some hoops with reg that was
special right you still got it you still
got it and then fritzy right on cue wow
25 i didn't plan it i was left john luck
no it wasn't on don't ever no
you know the guy that shoots and you you
might get hit in the head yeah and
that's todd todd when he takes that all
he does is take these hook shots from
twenty four he's playing with me because
it ricochets wildly off the rim or the
backboard and they're like [ __ ] funny
uh dp's show during super week brought
to you by panini america the official
trading cards of the dan patrick show we
were talking about you know how guys
normally say they're taller than what
they really are right like did you lie
about how tall you were yes uh
in high school i was
six four i said i was six six okay i
grew into six six yeah and eventually
six seven
um but yeah you always wanna like
say you're taller than you really are
like charles everyone thought charles
was six seven no dude you're six three
you're six four yeah that was amazing
first time i stood next next to charles
and i went he's not that much you were
looking
you're probably looking down on charles
right yeah you were looking down on
charles i i still the most one of the
most amazing players when you think at
that size what he was able to do yes and
maybe underrated but i wonder if if he
had gotten
you know somebody gotten with him and
said i'm gonna mold you into something
more
would charles have been able to do that
and be
i think someone did i think someone did
in phoenix it was moses malone while he
was still in philly oh he admits his
first couple years
hey
i'm from leeds alabama i'm happy to be
here i i like my food he was too heavy
and
between moses and
dr j they're the ones who got him on the
diet and had him shed all that weight
and kind of molded him into the type of
basketball player
that he eventually became these guys
when it was a few years ago they saw dr
j at the airport
and
i i was having breakfast or something
they go they came over there like dr j
is right and i said well go with him and
you could see these guys running after
dr j
and
there's just so such grace
attached to dr j when he moves yes it's
just there's something about just the
way he walked like his gate you know
what i mean and he was just strolling
down he was the coolest dude i've ever
seen if if dr j was uh an actor i think
he he would be like uh bond double o
seven that's how we perceive dr j just
cool nothing phased him
under pressure could handle anything
that's how we perceive dr j as bond
double 07. i always looked at him and i
i thought if if you could see jazz
moving
yes that's just yes
and like there's certain guys if you if
you attached music to them
dr j was always coltrane or yes you know
felonious miles yeah
yeah something about it uh this day in
sports history pauline uh just for
reggie's reaction in 1994 michael jordan
signed a contract to play for the
chicago white sox baseball it was the
best day of my life
it was the best day i i i remember this
vividly
uh what's the date
january 1994 february 1994. sitting on
the uh training table in indiana
uh your former network is on
sportscenter everything's breaking in
and all that
and he's getting ready to sign that and
i'm thinking i'm getting my ankles taped
i'm thinking
ding
the wicked witches did yes it was the
best day go
get away
be gone and then he came back
and who did he come back again
ding dong the witches here the witches
here the witches here against my beloved
pacers and myself
did you did you think that maybe he
wasn't gonna be what he once was
i knew he was going to be because
in between that time he filmed space jam
and we were out here he filmed it out
here on the warner brothers lot and he
had the
jordan dome erected where he had to be
able to work out and all that so we
would come over
and scrimmage with him he filmed all day
and open run started like around seven
o'clock with all the pros and everyone
wanted to say well let's see what
michael jordan's going to look like you
know
[Music]
he looked like mike felt like mike
elbowed like mike quick step like mike
so i knew
i knew he was coming back
what we learned brought to you by
draftkings download the draftkings app
use the promo code patrick get a free
shot at millions of dollars up for grabs
this week your first deposit minimum
five dollar deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details the great reggie miller will
be on the call bucks sons thursday night
aloysius thank you buddy oh so good to
be back with family we'll do it again
tomorrow and patrick show